let's bring in someone who was there
last night georgia gop congressman
doug collins congressman thanks for
being here this morning the president
was in familiar form last night we got
you almost to take for granted how often
he did rallies like this i believe this
was his first
post election what was it like to be
there and set the stakes of these
key georgia races well thank you it's
good to be with you all this morning
yeah it was it was this president is in
in his form and his element in doing
these rallies and last night he came to
georgia and he brought the truth he
brought the truth
of the fact that these two sentence
races are uh
so important in the future of america
this is not just now just two senate
races in georgia this is about actually
changing the direction
of the united states senate putting it
in the hands of chuck schumer
and an agenda that is is so radical left
that we cannot allow this to happen
and the president made it very clear
last night in in everything that's going
on he set the stage he said no matter
what
you may feel about the elections and how
the uh controversies have been going on
he made it very clear david perdue and
kelly lefler need to be elected because
john oscar and rafael warnock would take
this
country down a path that is too far
extreme and too far left and he made
that point very good he was in
he was in good form last night
congressman the president wasn't good
for him when it came to you he had some
very complimentary things to say
about you let's play a clip of that then
i want to ask you a question watch this
doug you want to run for governor in two
years
yeah good looking governor so
congressman let me ask you a pointed
but also a broadcast question as well
the point of question is do you want to
run for governor
in two years but the broader question is
this what should georgians make of
to some extent some messages that can
seem conflicting in other words there's
some doubt out there
about the trust in the system the voting
system there is as you can hear there
some frustration with governor brian
kemp the secretary of state as well
but also a recognition of how important
these two senatorial races are so
the broad question is what should
georgians think about the entire state
of these messages and what they should
be doing and pointedly
are you interested in running for
governor well i appreciate the president
he's a good friend and he made that
comment last night the only political
decision i'm looking at right now
is helping david perdue and kelly
leftwick get elected and and i don't
think there's two messages here i don't
think there's two conflicting messages
it's a it's an anomaly to actually say
that you have to decide to make sure
that our elections have the integrity
they need that everybody show up
and everybody vote and at the same time
make sure that everybody does show up
and vote for keller leflar and david
perdue
those are not conflicting messages those
are honest messages remember we just
i just dealt with uh four years of a
democratic party that to this day still
never recognize donald trump is the
president the hashtag not my president
i mean all the investigations everything
that i had to live through with
impeachment
this president was never accepted the
election was never accepted a few years
ago why don't we allow a little bit of
time to go through here where the
president can have his legal challenges
we can make sure that the elections are
safe secure and every legal vote is
counted especially here in georgia as we
prepare for these two
election races coming up for kelly
leflan and david purdue
but again i think that the president was
just making the clear point that we can
do more than one thing at a time we can
make sure our elections are safe
while at the same time ensuring the
senate does not go to the radical left
congressman let's talk covet 19 relief a
lot of businesses around the country
getting increasingly concerned
increasingly desperate for that relief
nancy pelosi now coming out
saying that she's okay with a smaller
bill the timing of that obviously
terribly interesting and highly
political bernie sanders now saying
though
a new 900 billion dollar bipartisan
proposal should not pass
so the truth is here that while
politicians are arguing about it
people are just out there needing help
where does this land when does the help
arrive
well that's a great question but you
know look there would be no bill
helpful to bernie sanders it wasn't
really basically a government take over
our economy so let's just be honest
about that and put him to the side
and then look at the put under the
dictionary political hypocrisy would be
nancy pelosi
the speaker who all through the fall and
alpha would never come to the table and
discuss getting relief
before the election and then
miraculously now that she believes that
joe biden won the election the vaccines
around the corner said
okay i'll look at something different
that is despicable what the speaker said
the other day
and not playing politics and now playing
politics with copenhagen
goes to exactly what you said yet are
there people out there who are hurting
right now
we've wanted to see relief targeted our
businesses target those communities
that need this help and the president
last night spoke about this in the
in the rally when he said he wants to
see this relief happen
nancy speaker pelosi ought to be ashamed
of herself for actually now
showing what we've known all along and
that is uh that this is a political
decision for her that she's uh
been saying the only good thing i guess
from strictly pelosi is is that now she
just admitted what we've known all along
she played politics with people's lives
on covent response
absolutely she said it couldn't be lower
than two trillion dollars now here we
are
at 900 billion it makes no sense
and then other other than through a
political lens
congressman doug collins come back after
this special election and we'll talk
we'll
make will ask you the same question and
then force you to actually answer it
all right about whether you want to run
for governor you all have a good time
y'all
y'all take care we appreciate it thank
you very much sir